hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game and a very nice story about
um a six-year-old girl from India she
could be seven now but the games are
from when she was six years old as this
is the under seven Championship uh
called sharvanika
um interestingly I've seen an interview
with her with chagasha from chess base
India and he calls her uh sharvanika but
then he asks her uh what's it actually
pronounced and she says sharvanika and
then he just continues calling her
charvanika so I don't really understand
how how that works uh but I'm gonna do
it as she she says so I'm gonna I call
her sharvanika and also uh interesting
uh story I I thought okay there's no way
I'm gonna find the photo of her opponent
because okay sharlanika's photo was
published by chess base India but not
only does uh Kiana here have a photo of
herself online uh she also already has a
YouTube channel so if you guys are
interested in following her progress I
will put a link to her YouTube channel
also in the description below uh with
the article to the just based India's
Channel now what I found interesting and
I usually find these stories on Twitter
where you know there's a whole lot about
Chess uh
published it and saying that sharvanica
is a 100
um uh girl from India saying that she
wins all of her events with 100 uh
saying that she won the uh what's it
called into in 2022 she won the
Nationals under seven championship and
also uh with a score of 11 out of 11 and
then she won in the in Sri Lanka the
Asian school championship she won the
under seven classical tournament she won
the under seven rapid tournament and she
won the under seven Blitz tournament all
of them with 100 and you might think
okay they are six years old uh probably
those games are not maybe the the most
top level games that we are used to and
uh chances are her opponents are just
blundering pieces but if you are
thinking that you could not be further
from the true truth and this is one of
the games that I'm going to show you
it's an extremely top level game it has
a brilliant opening brilliant middle
game and a brilliant finish to the game
uh so without further Ado let's check it
out so sharanika with the white pieces
opens with D4 we have Knight to F6 by
Kiana C for E6 Knight to F3 and pawn to
D5 so okay the Queen's Gambit declined
is on the board G3 sharvanica goes for
the uh the uh Catalan opening with the
chapter E7 and now Bishop to G2 both
players Castle so castles castles and
pawn to C6 now this is all a modern
Theory to the to the highest level
Knight beta D2 We have Knight beat the
D7 and now Queen to C2 nicely developing
pieces putting them on optimal squares
B6 preparing Bishop to B7 and now Pawn
to e for striking in the center D
countries and C4 we have Knight captures
on C4 and the bishop to B7 preparing to
bring the Rook the C8 and sharvanica
still has to figure out where to develop
the bishop maybe to E3 or to F4 or to G5
to get that Rook to C1 or or maybe The
Rook will come to D1 this Rook will come
to E1 all depends on uh how the game
continues so she goes Rook to D1 first
which is also a very well known move
quanta C5 striking in the center we have
Knight F the E5 and this is where the
game takes the most interesting turn now
we are already at move 12 and for
example this exact position was reached
in 2020 in the Gibraltar Masters between
Martin percivali and Van GAO who was uh
I mean a member of the candidates
tournament uh so okay Knight captures on
E5 and this is a new move that has not
been reached before uh how you should
play this and how the theory suggest you
should play this as C characters on D5
and then we'll capture on D4 and then
Queen to C7 and so on and so on black
brings the Rooks into the game however
here Knight captures an E5 was played
which seems like a good idea uh but it
allows white a very very tricky maneuver
D captures an E5 and it seems like
you're gonna lose a piece because your
queen and Knight are hanging but not
really okay black is fine here Knight
after D7 and now Queen to A4 shardvanica
puts pressure on the Knight here and
Bishop to C8 uh just uh nicely defending
uh so what uh what can you do here
interestingly you don't you don't really
have to do this you could also play
Queen to E8 it's such a fun position and
now for example if Rook captures uh here
it just Rook the d8 and you can't
capture because uh the the queen would
hang so even this is possible but okay
Bishop to C8 was played in the game this
allows white to really put a white
really put pressure on black Bishop to
F4 sharlanika knows now wants to put a
knight on D6 we have Queen to C7 and
pinning from the rook and now Knight to
D6 we have rooked the d8 and now Rook 8
to C1 and here the problem is if you go
for Knight captures an E5 and sharmanika
mentions this during her interview with
shagar Shah she says that she saw if
Knight captures an E5 that black can't
really uh completely untangle here
because after Bishop captures on E5 and
Bishop captures on D6 Rook captures on
D6 and after Rook captures Bishop
captures Queen captures there is the
very nice Queen to E8 um sorry not Queen
to E8 but E5 uh just attacking the rook
and the queen so that's that that's
resigns for black so after Rook 8 to C1
Knight the f8 was played and now uh
shermanica gets a different idea that uh
sort of a sort of a trap for black
Bishop to E3 and now it seems like you
should be able to play this because
there aren't any tricks and also the the
d8 square will be covered if Queen to E8
ever wants to be played but uh here
Kiana still goes for Bishop captures on
D6 e captures on D6 Rook captures on D6
but now it turns out it is all the same
Rook captures Queen cap address and
point the E5 now attacking the queen and
the undefended rook and on A8 but of
course just clean the B8 you will give
up the exchange and then the black queen
will control this long diagonal and with
the light core Bishop this could still
pose a lot of problems for
uh for white however you don't have to
do this you could also play something
else so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the absolute best move for
white uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not grabbing The
Rook as I already told you not to do
that and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Queen to C6 this
is now winning a full piece as you
cannot defend that Rook so how do you
how do you continue this uh Bishop to B7
you could uh of course it's better to
give up the bishop than the rock Queen
capture Sun B7 Queen captures Bishop
captures and now Rook the d8 and okay
black will still fight uh no point in
resigning right away and we're gonna
skip this part of the game because
what's interesting is how uh the game
concludes okay white is still up a piece
for the rest of the game some points
will be traded some points will be
captured and this is where the fun again
starts A5 uh you cannot capture because
the Rook would be a hanging on B2 C4
Kiana also starts advancing her past
Pawn eight captures on B6 C3 and now
Bishop to E4 it seems like you are
starting the some squares but not really
point the C2 and here you can win this
in two really really cool ways but
umanika chooses a much cooler way so you
could win this by simply capturing the
pawn and your position is still winning
let's say Rook captures here and now you
play Rook to f8 and it doesn't matter
what black does uh you're still gonna
win if you go Rook to B2 then you're
gonna uh win the F7 Pawn if King to G8
The Rook to F6 goes after the pawns here
and you will simply win this end game
and also if the Rook to B2 isn't played
if you go after the rope with something
like King to G7 then just the B7 and you
either take the rook and then the queen
enters the game or you defend and then
you have to give up a full Rook so this
is one way to do it with white but she
does it in a much uh a more interesting
way and instead of capturing she plays
Pawn to B7 uh sorry Rook the C8 and now
uh as it turns out uh there's really
nothing you can do Rook to B1 with check
King to G2 you and now see one Queen she
allows uh takiana to bring her Queen
into the game but now look at this Rook
captures on C1 Rook captures and now B7
showing that uh the B1 square is
defended by the bishop and of course the
C8 square is defended by the pawn so
there is no stopping that pawn from
becoming a queen and okay the game
concluded with Rook to C4 uh she got a
queen into the game Rook captures on e4
and she was able to outmaneuver uh her
uh with a queen against The Rook uh but
yeah absolutely stunning stuff and I
told you you guys would probably think
that okay they are six years old
probably they're just playing nonsense
moves and just blundering pieces all
over the place but as you've seen uh
after after 13 moves a position that was
reached in in in Gibraltar and then you
know very nicely concluded and even
after this uh Queen to be it Moon not
just going for some like Bishop capture
78 but also playing the the the the the
the the perfect Queen to see a C6 also
Queen T4 would have done the job but
yeah absolutely stunning game and now uh
now you know why and how she wins the
games and tournaments or tournaments
with with a score of 100 she she plays
uh you know brilliant chess uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and a bit of uh the story that I shared
I hope you enjoyed that and also I
wanted to mention uh I don't know if I
already mentioned this but uh yeah her
coach is uh this gentleman here I'm just
gonna try and find it uh this is her
coach who also coaches
um uh none other than gookish so she is
in very very good hands uh and uh we can
probably expect a lot more from her in
the future there you have it a nice
photo of her coach with uh with gookish
I forgot his name uh as I uh tend to
forget names uh much more uh than than I
did but yeah Grandmaster Vishnu prasanna
is is the name of the coach he's the
coach of the great bookish and he is now
coaching young uh sharmanika so uh not
not not at all uh surprised that shishu
wins her tournaments with 100 uh so yeah
hope you enjoyed that as well I would
like to
and Scott mellis for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you one of the
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and do check out the entire
article in the description below and
also if you want Kiana's YouTube channel
in the description below see you soon